die schweiz ein land in dem man gerne
lebt
ein land in dem eigentlich alles
funktioniert viele menschen tragen im
hintergrund dazu bei
tatiana lenze ist hier als team
reto baumgartner ist müllmann
marian price werk ist polizistin und
marktoberdorf arzt
wir leben diese menschen zu versetzen
sie sich ein
und was beschäftigt sie vier menschen
und ihr alltag ein tag im leben der
schweiz im mai morgens viertel 46
ein tag wie jeder andere 8 millionen
menschen stehen auf jeder mit seiner
eigenen geschichte
in balve bei luzern
in bern
gelungen im kanton abhalten
der tag nun seinen lauf
kurz nach sieben in widnau im kanton
aargau marian hat sich ihren traum
erfüllt und wohnt seit kurzem mit ihren
zwei kindern und ihrem freund als
patchwork familie zusammen mit pferden
hunden hühnern und katzen hier in
lungern fährt make zum letzten mal zur
arbeit
33 jahre lang war er dorfarzt hier nun
lässt er sich pensionieren
bald habe ich mich immer freut sich im
reed business heute praxiserfahrung
tierärztin tatiana und ihre hunde sind
eine wg auch draußen training
übernachten im auto und sich unter
dreijährige technik hat er super
spektrum also ich mich gelacht
ganz vorn im kanton aargau sind die
pferde versorgt varianz freund tobi ist
auch polizist aber in zürich
seit zwei jahren sind die beiden ein
paar
in luzern zwei kilo abfall pro tag
produziert jeder menschen der schweiz
das ist mehr als im umliegenden europa
die müllmänner müssen diesen dreck
einsammeln aber das macht nichts
es gibt schon eine frau
aber es muss ja gemacht
tatjana auf dem weg zu ihrem vormittags
job
sie schätzt es dass es so sauber ist in
der schweiz
als gute partie
einen halben tag pro woche übernimmt sie
in einem tierheim kratos den ärztlichen
dienst und kümmert sich um heimatlose
tiere
für marian ist es wichtig ein schönes
zuhause zu haben
sie ist in einem kinderheim aufgewachsen
und hat ihre leiblichen eltern nie
kennengelernt
die erste vier york da bin ich sie die
knapp 47 biz drückt
schwester mini liebliche adoptiert und
das ist relativ gut gehe und sie dann
aber immer kleider sind nicht versteht
jetzt keine traurigkeit und den hält
mini älteren entschlossen mich halt
adoptieren und den sie von den spielern
auskommen
ich glaub ich war nicht das was ich
jetzt bin wenn ich michael sonneck nicht
die chance bereitete
es ist 9
mel kursabschlag von etwa 2000 einwohner
er ist der einzige dorf kennt jede
familiengeschichte familiengeschichte
reto ist schon drei stunden unterwegs
heuschrecken
dankeschön
ja manchmal nach innsbruck
das kommt man jede these
oder 2
bei knapp 3000 haushalten rund um luzern
müssen sie heute müll einsammeln
wie das tecdax 27.000 haustiere werden
in der schweiz jedes jahr ausgesetzt die
meisten landen im tierheim zwei solche
runde hat tatjana selbst adoptiert
wir warten ab schafft in das neues velo
faktor jahresergebnis mini art wie mit
ihnen hätten definitiv so schön knöpfel
polizei marians dienst beginnt um 10
sie muss während eines fußballspiels den
verkehr regeln
bis jetzt einmal mir sitzt hier
das ist vom ruß abstand größten das
theater schafft nur drinnen ist und so
ist es jetzt glück hat das ist super
wir schliefen
dies war auf
aber
möllmann reto ist meist guter laune
viele leute kennen ihn und schalten
gerne in schwarz
momentan in gesprächen situation
schwierig ist für mich als erwartet
und seit fast zwei jahren
und verglichen und gar nichts letzten
bieten kann
gerichte wie bei der geburt das sind
fragen die gleichheit und
12 supertolle liam hemsworth und sind
gesund und und das hus und verstoßen
ein ungar
also ich bin zufrieden dass sie der
berge so mach ich es mir gemacht hat
kampf um die besten services
finde ich also und klage zurück und ist
aber das finde ich durch das könne
meister mitreden
passiert das nicht passieren
generiert
sagt und fährt los dem monitor muss
weitergehen
es ist 11
merck will dass die praxis im dorf
bleibt aber hausärzte sind knapp 8000
gibt es in der schweiz und die
nachkommen wollen lieber teilzeit in
gemeinschaftspraxen arbeiten aber
melkert jemanden gefunden der sich
interessiert hat resümiert all away ist
österreicher kommt aber ursprünglich aus
dem iran
die jungen aus dem dorf can't make seit
ihrer geburt bauer hans wurde von ein
paar kühen überrannt vielleicht ist der
meniskus gerissen
auch marian hat ihren traumberuf gewählt
seit 18 jahren ist sie bei der polizei
150 polizisten sind im einsatz wenn
basel fußball spielt ein fünftel der
ganzen belegschaft
der fernzug kommt an der heikelste
moment ist sicher wenn sie so alles
gesammelt mehrheitlich fcb-fans und
kiefer
heute sind des luzerner fans
das ist normal wenn man den haag
gestellt weil sie kanalisiert denn
bisher so die tür ist noch frisch
intensiv oder ein fiat fahrer kann das
sehr gesittet
es ist mittag die kirche von emmenbrücke
ist treffpunkt der müllmänner aus der
ganzen region
ala
ich male konnte sie sind seit 37 jahren
verheiratet tochter martina ist mit den
enkelinnen zu besuch
martina ist ebenfalls ärztin
natürlich stand zur diskussion ob sie
die praxis des vaters übernehmen soll
einfach praxis übernimmt martina
unmöglich mit 24 und prozent von morgen
machen das ganze administrativen
schieben und so ist das kommt einfach
nicht einfach englisch wenn so leute
wissen das ging jetzt eine zahnarzt
fahren wird die praxis über 90.000
schaffen blickt
nadal so der mediziner schaffen macht
es ist 2
jetzt sind auch die basel fenster
marian zählt sich auch dazu sie freut
sich immer auf diesen dienst und das
volksfest das dazugehört ich finde mit
dem hat einmal mehr den vorjahren 5 auf
den knopf zum verschieben er es mit ihm
nach dem verzicht auf das ist für ihn
ein großereignis ziel
zugleich steht damit auf tatjana ist
gerne trost die 44-jährige gönnt sich
und ihren hunden über mittag regelmäßig
zwei stunden spaziergang im wald
schienennetz ernstthal 15 jahre lang mit
betrüge hinter mir das hat nichts mit
normaler hund ist gut wie sie das
problem
die müll tour geht weiter
privat ist verrät wo alles unklar auch
im falle einer scheidung möchte er
unbedingt ein aktiver vater leiden
aber er hat angst dass das schwieriger
wird
august die tour keine frage nach der tat
und es speziell um die eigene tochter
erste option
das spiel der emotionen
wollten wir gern
für mich ist es müßig sie die
hausaufgaben und häufigen
wenn viel zeit und viel strenger und
weniger schön aber eine vom nächsten tag
aber eine bürgschaft von assisi das
spiel hat begonnen
erst jetzt können die polizisten pause
machen
marie anschaut was ihre kinder machen
die beiden sind mit ihrem vater in einem
dinosaurier park und immer er sich
lässig ist auch noch ganz tolle sache
mit ihnen und den weisen ganz genau sind
sie optimalen als bestens betreut
also ich war mit mehr unterhalt minuten
ein geheimnis es wäre es um aufnahmen zu
schaffen überhaupt
ja und ich können dass der händler
antizipiert wird
die sachen können
in lungern es ist rein
am nachmittag macht make hausbesuche und
nimmt reset viele patienten sind halt
und können nicht mehr in die praxis
kommen also gebürtige gebürtige iraner
die bilder dieser dialekt eine ziemliche
herausforderung selbst für schweizer
aber dass ich dir wichtiger kunde zum
heli rallye ist ein kaffee schnaps das
fleisch sicher gesund
man hofft dass das auch richtig lang das
ist die richtige entscheidung für ins
gesicht das ist natürlich wichtig hoffe
dass sich da wo fehlt da bin ich
zuversichtlich
ritters kollegen sind portugiesen 90
prozent der männer die auflagen sind
ausländer
bei den fahrern hingegen hat es mehr
schweizer
der wieder
aus mir kraft für uns schweizer sind vor
allem durch von bands im kern muss
landes gefahren wo mitgegangen
weil das ist was ich nur jedem raum des
russland wird sich sicher probenarbeit
und schweizer
manche wie wenig wenn ich im anderen
also ich überhaupt island nationalität
es ist 4
bereitschaftsdienst am ende des spiels
alle 150 polizisten sind wieder auf
ihrem posten
es kann immer zu ausschreitungen kommen
alles bleibt friedlich
marian fährt in die zentrale zurück
tatjana führt eine kleintierpraxis in
bern
am nachmittag hat sie termine im
viertelstundentakt henry hat ein
geschwür 70 prozent aller haushalte in
der schweiz halten tiere darunter
schätzungsweise 14 millionen kratzen und
500.000 runde
und natürlich ganz viele vögel fische
hamster und eben meerschweinchen
sie alle müssen medizinisch versorgt
werden
in der schweiz gibt es rund 3000
tierärzte die müllmänner auf dem weg zur
großen kehrichtverbrennung in berlin
128 km haben sie heute zurückgelegt
seit eineinhalb jahren ist die neue
anlage in betrieb hier wird der ganze
müll der zentralschweiz entsorgt
knapp 80 kübelwagen laden hier täglich
ab reto staunt immer wieder was alles
weggeworfen wird
mit 14 sitzen
probiert
rund ein drittel aller es waren landet
in der schweiz auf dem müll
oder anders gesagt zwei millionen tonnen
lebensmittel pro jahr
es ist 6 marian holt ihre kinder beim
vater ab die beiden haben die trennung
der eltern gut verkraftet entscheiden
sehr gut mitgemacht
hier hat marians früher mit ihrer
familie gewohnt
zu ihrem ex-mann hat sie immer noch ein
gutes verhältnis
er arbeitet beim bevölkerungsschutz lucy
und fing verbringen viel zeit mit ihm
sidney durch lange
eine halbe stunde mehr an hunger um 100
auf die schippe
und jetzt
auch reto ist fertig mit seinem dienst
heim kommen ist nicht einfach im moment
41 prozent aller ehen werden
verschiedene in der schweiz aber von den
kindern lässt sich das paar nichts
anmerken
frau geht ins training er übernimmt den
kinder dienst
während andere feierabend haben
engagiert sich tatjana ehrenamtlich
weiter
sie bildet für das schweizerische rote
kreuz rettungshunde aus rund 100 hunde
sind einsatzbereit falls sich irgendwo
eine katastrophe ereignet
es ist 7
melken sie müssen sich erst daran
gewöhnen wieder mehr zeit miteinander zu
verbringen
nein der weser der ganztags
frisbee spielen gehört bei marians neuer
familie zum abend wunderschönen ort die
innere uhr stimmt einfach
ich glaube wenn du so zufrieden darf im
laden
es war einmal ein kleines mädchen mitten
im dunkeln war der wald wurde dichter
und dichter plötzlich sah es eine große
wiese mit gänseblümchen anfangs besser
verstehen zu verfallen
auch tatjana ist vielleicht aber die
abendstunden mag sie nicht besonders
sie ist nicht gerne allein
vor einem halben jahr ist sie in ein
richtiges loch gefallen
nach seiner krise mit einem konzept
repeatern immer frisch zusammen hat das
brautpaar
ja
strukturell muss ins bett maßnahmen
jan o
hoffer
überall kehrt ruhe ein
mit cloud
reto musste rotkäppchen heute nur
dreimal verließen
ein tag im leben der schweiz geht zu
ende
für merck musste sogar ein ganzer
lebensabschnitt es gibt die möglichkeit
das gedacht
völlig neue möglichkeiten eröffnet wird
und das ist positiv wenn man sich nur
ein schreiben
morgen stehen sie wieder auf und mit
ihnen acht millionen andere menschen in
der schweiz jeder mit seinem alltag und
mit seiner geschichte
nächste woche riccardo amato sprengt
löcher in die schweizer halten
berka den nazi hütet schafe im
gotthardgebiet
rot wäre ist feuerwehrmann
und christine festland hilft babys zu
hause zur welt zu bringen